whenever you hear anybody talk about
this YouTube game they say make videos
on what you're passionate about so I'm
gonna do just that
in honor of Dark Souls remastered we're
going to talk about the absolute worst
part of the souls series or at least the
worst part for me and that's long
pointless runs back to boss fights if
you're familiar with souls you should be
very aware of what I'm talking about
every boss is located some distance away
from Oban fire the game's checkpoint
system and because most bosses do not
succumb to the player's blade on try one
we must rerun that route from the
bonfire to the boss every time we lose
to the boss and die which happens a lot
in Dark Souls As I am talking about my
own view here let's begin with the story
about how I first started playing the
souls series and how these run backs
have always been my bait I had heard
some of my friends talk about how great
Dark Souls 1 was and how it ruined other
games for them cuz it was just so good I
wanted to put that to the test
so I got Dark Souls prepare to die
edition on Steam during a sale and
despite it crashing every time I touched
the PC settings tab I gave it a go I
play consistently right up to the Taurus
demon the first real boss of the game I
could not kill him for the life of me I
get into the fight hit him once or twice
to try to dodge and horribly fail either
getting killed or knocked off the edge
of the bridge and every time I died I
respawn at the undead burg bonfire and
made my way back I heard a rumor that
enemies stopped responding if you kill
them enough time but after killing every
husk of a skeleton standing between me
and tourists probably a dozen times I
became disheartened with that theory I
took to running past them I would often
get stalked hit and killed because I was
inexperienced at the game and the
enemies but even then it took less time
than killing every single one of them
every run back to Taurus keep in mind
that whenever I did make it to the boss
I was hardly progressing never landing
more than a single-digit number of hits
before being flattened like a pancake or
flung off the edge of the wall I
eventually got so fed up that I had to
put the game down I would return
maybe in a day a couple of days a week
and try again the process would repeat
and I would take another break from the
game run fight die run fight die run
fight die repeat repeat repeat months
went by and I still hadn't gotten past
the game's first real ball I was upset
at the boss assuredly I didn't think the
bridge was a big enough marina and there
were some massive clipping problems due
to horses size relative to the bridge
they being similar widths but what I was
more frustrated at was how the vast
majority of my time in this endeavor was
not spent learning how to defeat this
boss and growing more accustomed to his
moveset it was spent running from
bonfire to fog wall because each
instance of time of the running was much
greater than the amount of time I lasted
inside the boss fight the running was
not enjoyable gameplay
nor was it engaging that was memorizing
a short button sequence and having to
repeat it every time I wanted to try and
beat tourists in the end I was probably
very close to dropping the game for good
but luckily through a friend or some
guide online I learned that Taurus is
super easy to kill if you go up the
ladder and plunging attack in ad mortem
after learning this tourist took me one
or two more tries
and it was a rushed have finally
vanquished the boss that delayed me for
months and actually get to explore the
rest of the game
meet Solaire and discover branching
world paths exhilarating now if I am
honest the added requirement of having
to make the run back to Taurus which
isn't even a particularly long run in
regard to the series did make the
accomplishment of beating him even
sweeter it made each attempt a bit
harder because I had to do something
else to get the chance to fight torts
but it did not achieve this in a good
way or I should say a way that I liked
it did not achieve this through giving
me engage in combat it did not achieve
this through giving me a thoughtful
challenge it did not achieve this
through giving me a learning opportunity
it achieved this by making me hold
forward on the analog stick and pressing
the B button sure I turn the camera a
few times but that was all the run up to
the boss amounted to it's all the run up
to any boss amounts to an amazingly
basic button combination that must be
executed for around a minute every time
I wish to challenge your boss now I
could fight every enemy every single
times I make that would make the
gameplay more engaging and complex to
some degree but the amount of time that
it would take to fight every preceding
enemy every time I ever challenged a
boss in a souls game would probably be
analogous to the entirety of the time I
put into the series as a whole as
example I must have died to the abyss
Watchers and Dark Souls 3 upwards of 30
times so what good would it have done to
stop and kill all the grooves in that
situation every time I would not have
benefited in any significant way from
farming basic enemies over and over and
over after the entire preceding swamp
and the first two to three runs I would
know their move set and can expect what
they'll do you could say I would level
up a few times making the boss easier
but my problem with most bosses is not
that I don't do enough damage or an
underleveled sometimes that's the case
but more often than not I just don't
know their kit well enough and the only
way to learn their kit and moveset is to
fight the boss so the only sensible
option I am left with is running past
these meaningless enemies time and time
again
many if not most of these runs are not
hard the run to the abyss Watchers is a
great example of that it's practically a
straight line with one left turn at the
end and you're at the boss it's trivial
to complete so if it's so easy why not
just do it well part of the reason is
because it is so easy run ups to fog
walls equate to a bad game of Dance
Dance Revolution or osoo where instead
of a consistent string of commands that
I have to input in precise order lining
up with music or what have you the whole
game is just up on the left stick and
hold B maybe sometimes press B maybe
sometimes slightly swerve the right
stick for convenience of uni and that is
about the entirety of engagement I feel
in these run ups
Dark Souls 2 has a prime example of the
futility of this mechanic because of
course Dark Souls 2 does that I think
will garner some sympathy for my
position the run-up to the final boss in
Dark Souls 2 includes a door that you
have to wait a bit to open and a long
narrow walkway with no enemies to open
the door you have to equip a ring which
serves no other function so for the
final fight you'll want to switch that
ring slot back to something useful this
is an inventory process you'll do every
time you make an attempt on the boss and
then you run for about a minute going in
essentially a straight line
and then you get to the boss fight if
you're like me you'll die and get to
repeat this whole process if you die
again repeat again every time learning
nothing new in the minutes wasted by the
game forcing you to open the door and
run back to the fog wall if someone can
defend this please do it makes the bill
up to the first fight the mattock yes
but any secondary attempts is rendered
annoying horribly so by this long
pointless walk funnily enough at this
moment I still haven't beaten dark souls
twos final boss because of this
pointless pathway I got so fed up with
the walk that I haven't bothered to make
it again I don't need extra time to
think about the bosses attacks or a fury
to cool off
I can do both of those things without
any help from the game so these run bags
don't need to be there for that reason
it also comes down to one of the core
dichotomies in the soul series and that
is between world exploration and boss
fights you can split any of the games up
into these two categories and see two of
the main focuses from soft crafted
experiences based around long tent
sections of world and level exploration
followed up by climactic boss fights the
idea that one has to repeat a small
chunk of the world exploration side of
things
every time they fail and want to retry a
boss fight attempt it doesn't make much
sense to me especially when it's an
intensely neutered version of that
exploration because it is simply running
through the level and not actually
exploring it and the games are often
designed around the player dying two
bosses at least a couple of times so to
forcibly tacked on a wanting version of
the world exploration to every boss
fight doesn't seem to fit I can't
entertain any real reason to have these
run back I mean if someone can defend
the design choice of the minute plus
straight walk at the end of Dark Souls 2
please please do write a comment make a
video anything I felt this way the first
time I play the original Dark Souls and
I felt this way with each successive
title I've taken a crack at it
unfortunately has never gotten better
now a bit contrary to what some let you
think I'm not going to be offering a
solution it would be a bit arrogant of
me to try and claim one without taking
into account every single other game
design choice and consequence such a
shift in an integral part of the series
would cause and that would be much more
content than even a whole nother video
could contain so I do not end this video
with a solution resolution conclusion or
anything else like that just a thank you
for taking the time to listen to my case
against the worst feature in my eyes in
this beloved franchise I care about the
series so I like discussion about it
hopefully this can be a starting point
for some new discussions about one of
the most contentious issues I have with
the game especially conversations that
don't end with an unnecessarily
condescending and get good
for those of you that like my lower
explanations of soul stuff be on the
lookout I'm planning a video talking
about general lore and context for each
and every boss for Dark Souls remastered
it won't be super in-depth but more of a
look at why each boss is standing in
your way in a bit of their backstory
thank you for watching